foreign
I don't think I would tell my younger
self anything because that would mess
with the rules of like time travel and I
don't think I'd be able to make the same
choices that ultimately led me to this
present moment
I first started up I think performing
when I think about just even like doing
church plays like I think my first
introduction to and all of this was
performing and from the Performing
getting into comedies I was in middle
school and I had a Drama teacher who was
just like you should try this so I did
then when I was in college I think that
sort of bug just it didn't really die I
was studying teaching at the time but I
just I was like I think I'm lying to
myself this idea that I can just like
keep doing comedy at night and like
while working a full-time job I was like
working jobs like at UCB the comedy
theater and I was like doing stand up
the whole time I kind of just wanted to
see if it was possible
it was
nerve-wracking because I didn't really
know many people who were in that field
and I think I just didn't know what an
actual job could look like but as soon
as I started meeting people who I was
like oh you can have health insurance
and do this that made me feel a little
bit more comfortable making that because
going to school interning starting to
get PA jobs you start to realize just
like the the breadth of jobs that are in
this business and how exciting that is
and doing that is what sort of taught me
the power of writing and it made me want
to learn how to write so that I could
maybe write something for myself or you
know just become a better performer but
in that process of learning more about
writing studying writing I also realized
I wanted to write for other people and
just yeah grow as much as possible in
that Arena
getting more into the business side as a
creative has been really hard I don't do
this because I'm good at math or like
logic that's definitely been like a an
area of of growing but one that really
excites me I love like
I don't know I feel like this it's all
like one big puzzle like you know when
you're writing a script that's one type
of puzzle when you're on set figuring
out how that's going to work the type of
set it's going to be it's all different
it's always moving you know it's
shifting there's just always so much to
learn so it's
been interesting
the thing about like going from a nine
to five to making your own hours is
actually like my least favorite part I
feel like people kind of don't realize
like even if you're at like the highest
level in your Fields like in the Arts
you're still kind of always a freelancer
and you're always trying to you know
make your own lane and your own path in
different places so that's sort of like
instability I think is what scared me
initially and still makes me a little
nervous sometimes but can also be cool
it can also be nice to not necessarily
have like I don't know a boss you have
to report to or like a weird photocopy
machine
there's a lot that I'm excited about for
a lot of reasons because they were fun
to do there's an animated Netflix
special called we lost our humans that
should be coming out sometime soon and
also wrap this movie bottom so that's
directed by Emma Seligman and
co-starring now so co-written by Rachel
Senate season two of the bear at some
point yeah
my dad said something to me the other
day where our last name debris is a it's
Nigerian and it's basically from like
our specific tribe I think my granddad
kind of made it up and he was like it's
really cool he's like now people know
the every name and even if they can't
totally pronounce it I'm like that for
me feels like enough that's pretty cool
that like my family's proud of me I'm
good with that